Continuing in Al Wajeez, in in the book
of purification, the chapters
of wudu. We are in the sub chapter
regarding my used to have blue. The
whole and will do.
The instances
or scenarios or times in which it is
preferred that a person have will do.
It is preferred that a person highly
encouraged that a person have will do
for these occasions. Now,
obligation,
that's different. We have three
instances that a person must have will
do
in order to engage in these three
actions.
Number one is salah. Number two is the
laugh around the Kaaba. Number three is
touching or handling the most half the
Quran.
Now, as far as the instances in which it
is preferred that a person have will do.
The author mentions nine of these
instances.
We've thus far discussed six of them.
just very quickly
at for the occasion of any remembrance
of Allah.
When a person wishes to sleep,
if a person is in a state of janaba, if
he wishes to eat or drink or sleep or
have relations a second time.
The fourth is making will do before
bathing always. Making will do
as
a prelude to bathing.
Number five is making will do after
eating something that has been cooked on
an open flame.
Number six is what we mentioned
yesterday, which is making will do for
each prayer, for each salah. And when we
say each salah, what's meant by that is
each time we stand to make salat.
Right? So, let's say for instance a
person wishes to make salat of Dhuhr,
they're going to make two rakat and
then,
you know, the the fard and then two
rakat,
making wudu once for all of this. So,
the entire
moment of prayer,
right? And then when salat al-asr comes,
they make wudu another time even if they
already have wudu.
Right? And that's how it used to be.
That's how it was obligated in the very
beginning. It was obligatory to make
wudu for every salat. And then later
that was relaxed in the very last year
of the prophet's life. As a matter of
fact, roughly 4 months before his death,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
that was relaxed and it became highly
encouraged to make wudu for each salat,
but no longer obligated. Or this was
relaxed earlier
during the conquest of Mecca.
The
verse of surat al-Ma'idah,
ya ayyuhallazina amanu idhā qumtum ila
[Arabic recitation]
ila ākhirihi,
this was revealed with surat al-Ma'idah
altogether. And surat al-Ma'idah was
revealed during Hajjatul Wada, which is
in the ninth year after hijrah.
Right?
However,
we
read the narration
of Buraydah yesterday,
Buraydah ibn al-Husayb, radiyallahu
anhu,
in which the prophet, sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, made wudu and then made all of
the remaining prayers of the day on that
same wudu that he made in the morning.
And this was during the conquest of
Mecca. So,
at the earliest, that's when this was
relaxed, and at the latest, it was in
last year of his life.
Now, the seventh instance in which it is
preferred that a person make wudu.
[Silence]
The author tells us that the seventh
time
when it is the sunnah and encouraged
that a person make wudu is anytime he
breaks his wudu.
Anytime the person breaks his wudu, uses
the restroom, or
their wudu is is is broken, to make
wudu. Why? Because in all of your
conscious time, and even in your
sleeping time, it is highly preferred
that a person have wudu. That a person
have constant wudu.
[Silence]
The
obviously is a reference to Bilal ibn
[Arabic recitation]
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
muezzin in Medina. And he was actually a
slave that was purchased by Abu Bakr
[Arabic recitation]
early days in Mecca because he he saw
that his masters were torturing him. So,
Abu Bakr as-Siddiq actually purchased
him for ex-
for
a a a reasonable you know, a reasonably
high
amount of money
and the master their masters, his
masters
didn't want to sell him at first. They
wanted to keep him because they wanted
to break his spirit, but they were
unable to do so. He broke their spirits
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's will. And
so,
finally, they just wanted to get rid of
him.
And so, Abu Bakr as-Siddiq purchased him
and then he he emancipated him, radi
[Arabic recitation]
maula
to Abu Bakr as-Siddiq and he had
accepted Islam before this and he made
hijrah. He was there for all of the
[Arabic recitation]
made hijrah. He was there for all of the
major battles. I think most of us know
[Arabic recitation]
notably what he is known for is he was
one of the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam's two mu'adhdhin mu'adh-
mu'adhdhins. I don't using like
mu'adhdhins, but
ahadi mu'adhdhinay an nabi sallallahu
alayhi wasallam in Medina. He had
Bilal ibn Rabah, and he had who was the
primary, and then Abdullah
ibn
Ummi Maktum or Amr ibn Ummi Maktum, radi
[Arabic recitation]
And so, Bilal was also a servant to the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam. He's
with him for all of his major battles.
And
[Arabic recitation]
his
the way that they did things in
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
time for
the prayer is that he would make the
adhan on time.
And then he would be in the masjid, and
people would come in, and they would
trickle in, and when he sees that
the majority of the people are there, he
would
make the iqama, or
and then he would go to the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam, and he would
tell him
"It's time for salah." And he would come
out, sallallahu alayhi wasallam, and
they would line up for salah, and then
he would lead them in salah.
And so, this went on for 10 years.
10 years this went on. So, the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam was very well
acquainted with Bilal and well
acquainted with Bilal's
footsteps, you know, like
have I heard someone
walking so much that
by the cadence of their walk, you know,
that that is them, you know,
because he's always listening to hear
when Bilal is coming because it's time
for salah.
And so
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
here
he says
Buraydah tells us that one day
the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
woke up, meaning from sleep, and he
called Bilal.
And so Bilal came and he said, "Yeah,
Bilal,
bima sabaqtani ila jannah?
Inni dakhaltul barihal jannah fasami'tu
khashkhashatak amami.
Khashkhashatak ya'ni saut khashkhashat
qadamayk, ya'ni mashiyatak
amami fil jannah."
And so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was sleeping, he woke up from
his sleep and he called for Bilal. And
when Bilal came, he said, "Bilal,
what did you do, what did you manage to
do, what have you what do you do to have
managed to have entered paradise before
me?
Yesterday, I entered paradise and I
heard your footsteps in front of me
in paradise." Faqala Bilal, "Ya Rasul
Allah, ma adhannu qatt illa sallaytu
rak'atayn.
Wala asabani hadathun qatt illa
tawaddha'tu indah."
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam said, "What do you do to have
managed to have gotten to paradise
before me because I entered paradise
last night and I heard the sound of your
footsteps in front of me therein. And
so, Bilal said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
I have not made adhan ever except that I
will make two raka' directly after
making adhan, always."
And
also, I do not break my wudu and have
never broken my wudu ever except that I
would always make my wudu again right
after. All right, so he's always in a
state of wudu. And so, the messenger of
Allah salallahu alayhi wasallam said,
"Lihadha, for this reason." This is This
is the reason. And
this is an important point
that he would always
make
two raka' after adhan.
And this is one of the evidences that
the scholars use
that how much time should be between
adhan and iqama. They say,
"At least enough time for two raka'."
At least enough time for two raka'. As
a matter of fact, these two raka' are
so highly encouraged by the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasallam that they are
almost
obligatory.
Almost wajib.
Because in a narration he says "Bayna
kulli adhanayni rak'atani.
Bayna kulli adhanayni rak'atani. Bayna
kulli adhanayni rak'atani
liman sha'."
He said in a narration between the every
adhan and iqama is two rak'.
Then he repeated it again. Between every
adhan and iqama is two rak'. Between
every adhan and iqama is two rak'. So,
he said it three times and then he said,
almost reluctantly,
"For whoever wants to."
Meaning
it's just short of being obligatory.
this is how the companions,
radiyallahu anhum, would usually behave
between adhan and iqama.
Not
stand around chit-chatting
and lollygagging between adhan and
iqama. This is This happens, right? This
happens. You don't see someone, you come
into the masjid, you see him, you talk
to him. That's okay. But this to become
our custom
to the point that if you come into the
masjid and want to make two rak', you
can't
because they're going to see me and I
have to entertain them. And if I don't
entertain them, they're going to think
something is wrong with me because I'm
not chit-chatting and lollygagging
before adhan and iqama because we all
know that between adhan and iqama, this
is the prime time
to chat about the weather, or to chat
about the news, or to chat about how fat
someone is getting, or how skinny
someone is getting, or how much weight
he lost, or how wet or dry it is
outside. And what happens, The days of
our lives are slipping through our
fingers just sand.
Just absolutely hemorrhaging time left
and right.
How much time is there between adhan and
iqama? Usually, about 5 or 10 minutes.
Imagine if all you did, all you change
in your life, nothing else.
You say, "From now on,
from now on, this is the only thing I'm
going to change in my life right now. I
have a lot of bad things going on in my
life that I shouldn't be doing.
A lot of good things that I should be
doing.
But, I can't change everything right
now. I'm going to change one thing.
I am going to be in the masjid for every
adhan from now on,
and I am going to spend every moment
between adhan and iqama either in salah
or making dua.
What would change in our lives?
Everything.
Literally, everything would change.
This is what the companions did. They
didn't get to paradise by doing these
great big amazing acts. No, some of them
did, but most of them, they got to
paradise by what?
One step at a time.
Right?
But, what happens is the masjid turns
into a certain culture where it becomes
almost impossible to come here just to
worship Allah. You can't do that
anymore.
Right?
You cannot come in and just make salah
because there's people talking and
chatting and walking back and forth and
joking and and so, I I can't really
focus in my prayer. And so, the real
good prayer is at home in my house. But,
at the masjid, that's kind of you
know, it's kind of a rotary club.
That's where we go to hang out. We pray,
we make salah, but the bulk of our time
is spent hanging out and chit-chatting.
It cannot be this because if the
masjid turns into this, where are we
going to go to get away from the dunya?
Where?
Speaking, talking, interacting in the
masjid should always be incidental.
And as we continue through the sunan of
salah and masajid in the future
chapters, we'll see how the prophet
saw
these same
habits start to come up in the masjid.
Talking, chatting, hanging out too much
to where it would start to impede impede
worship and how he put a stop to it.
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. And we will
learn that inshallah. Nas'alullah
subhanahu wa ta'ala an yu'allimana
min dinina ma jahilna wa an yanfa'ana
bima allamana minhu. As'alullah ta'ala
an yubarika li walakum fil Qur'anil Azim
wa an yanfa'ani wa iyyakum bima fihi
minal ayat wadh-dhikril Hakim. Wallahu
[Arabic recitation]
ashabihi ajma'in. Walhamdulillahi Rabbil
Alamin.